but we're going to begin with the news
this morning and that is the latest
outbreak in a deadly 2023 tornado season
a wave of severe storms hammered
Oklahoma Kansas and Iowa last night and
people in central Oklahoma reported
several tornadoes leading to severe
damage you see it on your screen now one
of them is blamed for killing two people
in Coal Oklahoma a little town 25 miles
south of Oklahoma City as Janet shamlin
shows us survivors say the power of that
twister in particular was terrifying
looked like a bomb went off it was a
Devastation Dennis and Michelle Newberg
and their words say their home was wiped
off the face of the map escaping just
five minutes before a tornado destroyed
their house in Coal Oklahoma the tornado
that plowed to the community with a
population of about 600 decimated houses
and property and claimed at least two
lives it is reasonable to expect
possibly more based on the damage that
we've seen thus far the tornado warning
started early Wednesday evening it is
definitely violent and it is getting
bigger
first large hailstones pelted the area
just outside Oklahoma City
previewing what was to come that's on
the ground about 60 miles east of coal
another tornado touched down in Shawnee
our affiliate station KW TV in Oklahoma
City caught it live on air just as the
town's power went out oh look at that
that storm took aim at Oklahoma Baptist
University shredding walls of buildings
and leaving a trail of debris on campus
no injuries are reported my immediate
reaction can be like holy crap you know
because like there's a huge treat
overturned like there was glass that was
like staying glass beautiful was
shattered for CBS mornings I'm Janet
shamlian